in a previous video we defined this
random variable X it's a discrete random
variable it can only take on a finite
number of values and I defined it as the
number of workouts I might do in a week
and we calculated the expected value of
our random variable X which you could
also denote as the mean of X and we use
the Greek letter mu which we use for
population mean and all we did is it's
the probability weighted sum of the
various outcomes and we got for this
random variable with this probability
distribution we got an expected value or
a mean of 2.1 we're going to do now is
extend this idea to measuring spread and
so we're going to think about what is
the variance of this random variable and
then we could take the square root of
that to find out what is the standard
deviation the way we are going to do
this has parallels with the way that
we've calculated variance in the past so
the variance of our random variable X
what we're going to do is take the
difference between each outcome and the
mean square that difference and then
we're going to multiply it by the
probability of that outcome so for
example for this first data point you're
going to have zero minus two point one
squared times the probability of getting
zero times zero point one then you're
going to get plus one minus two point
one squared times the probability that
you get one times zero point one five
then you're going to get plus two minus
two point one squared times the
probability that you get a two times
zero point four then you have plus three
minus 2 point 1 squared times zero point
two five and then last but not least you
have plus four minus 2 point 1 squared
times zero point one so once again the
difference between each outcome
and the mean we square it and we
multiply times the probability of that
outcome so this is going to be negative
two point one squared which is just two
point one squared so I'll just read this
is 2 point 1 squared times 0.1 that's
the first term and then we're going to
have plus one minus two point one is
negative one point one and then we're
going to square that so that's just
going to be the same thing as 1 point 1
squared which is one point two one but
I'll just write it out one point 1
squared times 0.15 and then this is
going to be two minus two point one is
negative point one when you square it is
going to be equal to so plus point zero
one if you have negative point one times
negative point one that's point zero one
times zero point four times point four
and then plus we this is going to be
zero point nine squared so that is 0.8
one times 0.25 and then we're almost
there this is going to be plus one point
nine squared one point nine squared
times point one and we get one point one
nine so this is all going to be equal to
one point one nine and if we want to get
the standard deviation for this random
variable and we would denote that with
the Greek letter Sigma the standard
deviation for the random variable X is
going to be equal to the square root of
the variance the square root of one
point one nine which is equal to let's
just get the calculator back here so we
are just going to take the square root
of what we just just type it again one
point one nine and that gives us so it's
approximately one point zero nine
approximately one point zero nine
so let's see if this makes sense let me
put this all on a number line right over
here so you have the outcome 0 1 2 3 & 4
so you have a 10% chance of getting a 0
so I will draw that like this let's just
say this is a height of 10% you have a
15% chance of getting 1 so that'll be
one and a half times higher so it'll
look something like this
you have a 40% chance of getting a 2 so
that's going to be like this so you get
a 40% chance of getting it too
you have a 25% chance of getting a 3
look like this and then you have a 10%
chance of getting a 4 so it look like
that so this is a visualization of this
discrete probability distribution where
I didn't draw the vertical axis here but
this would be 0.1 this would be 0.15
this is 0.25 and that is 0.4 and then we
see that the mean is at 2.1 if the mean
is the mean is a 2.1 which makes sense
even though this random variable only
takes on integer values you can have a
mean that takes on a non integer value
and then the standard deviation is one
point zero nine so one point zero nine
above the mean is going to get as close
to three point two and one point zero
nine below the mean is going to get as
close to one and so this all at least
intuitively feels reasonable this mean
does seem to be indicative of the
central tendency of this distribution
and the standard deviation does seem to
be a decent measure of the spread